alors avons nous changer notre façon de
faire nos courses depuis 18 mois réponse
avec vous emilie mayer bonjour vous êtes
expert et des produits de grande
consommation chez iris est ce que la
crise sanitaire ou pas d'ailleurs à
provoquer une espèce de rupture dans nos
habitudes est ce qu'il ya un avant et un
après alors directe d'homme comme dans
beaucoup de domaines à la crise elle n'a
pas vraiment amener des choses
radicalement nouvelle mais elle a plutôt
axelera accélérée des tendances qui
était déjà à l'oeuvre
des symptômes de sa très fort dans le
domaine de la consommation c'est la
digitalisation des courses mais on est
dans le domaine de l'accélération parce
que déjà en lui digital était sur une
pente ascendante avant la crise
sanitaire donc pas de rupture mais voilà
une espèce de transe pas transformation
pas d'accélération des tendances
préexistantes le digital donc ça veut
dire faire ses courses donc sur internet
et ensuite se faire livrer aller
chercher ses courses au drive c'est ça
ce qu'on appelle le digital oui c'est ça
alors en france le gros des courses
alimentaires c'est du drive donc
effectivement fait ses courses chez soi
et puis on va dans un point de retrait
dans un hyper dans un supermarché
chercher ses courses assez le modèle
dominant en france aujourd'hui le online
les courses alimentaires étaient déjà
très dynamique avant la crise sanitaire
elle est venue accélérer ça parce que
finalement au printemps de l'année
dernière les gens ont eu on a eu peur
ont voulu se protéger du virus et quelle
meilleure façon de se protéger quand on
fait ses courses que les faire derrière
son ordinateur d'aller au point de
retrait on ouvre son coffre on attend
nous mais les courses dans le coffre on
a croisé personne n'a touché aucun
produit donc c'est ce besoin de se
protéger a généré une grosse croissance
dans ce canal est amené effectivement
des gens qui fréquentaient pas forcément
le drive avant et c'est le cas des
seniors parce que c'était une population
qui a été très exposé au virus guard et
ils ont conservé cette habitude là ouais
on voit que la clientèle qui a été gagné
en fait à ce moment-là elle reste alors
que on est quand même dans une situation
sanitaire qui s'améliore qui se
normaliser pour autant le online et
courses online continue de progresser
parce que après la volonté de protéger
les gens découverte c'était quand même
une façon très pratique de faire ses
courses alors autre tendance qui s'est
renforcée la crise a favorisé les
commerces proximité on a aussi la
conserver cette habitude effectivement
il c'est de la bouche d'ailleurs pardon
qui se portait déjà bien avant la crise
et ça c'est pour ça qu'on est dans le
domaine de l'accélération comme dans le
digital les commerces de bouche allait
plutôt bien avant mais là on est
vraiment sur des croissances qui sont
extrêmement forte les bouchers
traditionnels les fromages et les
boulangers les poissonniers tous ces
commerces se porte très bien là ça a été
un peu c'est un peu né sous le joug de
la contrainte puisque l'année dernière
voilà on devait au printemps dernier pas
excéder 1 km autour de chez nous donc on
a fait nos courses autour de chez nous
dans des petites surfaces dans des
commerces traditionnels et puis
finalement les français ont découvert le
plaisir de ces commerces là et ça un an
après ça reste quand même assez présent
poste confinement est ce qu'on va de
moins en moins souvent faire ses courses
et ce qu'on y passe maintenant est ce
qu'il ya une volonté de la part des
français de de ne plus perdre entre
guillemets de temps faisant ses courses
pour passer plus de temps en famille
faire du sport des loisirs ouais on
observe çà les français vont aujourd'hui
moins souvent en hyper et supermarchés
qu'il n'y allais avant la crise
sanitaire on observe ce qu'on appelle
une baisse de ce trafic entre 5 et 10%
selon le format des magasins à esi vont
moins souvent alors du coup ils
remplissent un petit peu plus les
paniers les caddies à chaque fois qu'ils
y vivent mais effectivement les magasins
physiques souffre un peu d'une perte de
trafic et tout le monde j'imagine bien
sûr veut manger des produits de qualité
est ce que cette recherche de la qualité
ça a pris de l'importance aussi avec la
crise alors la recherche de qualité ça
date d'avant la crise a trop tendance
tout s'est accéléré ouais alors j'irai
qu'elle sait peut-être compléter cette
recherche de qualité je dirai ce qui
dominait dans la recherche de qualité
depuis le début des années 2010 et le
l'impact de la consommation sur sa santé
normalement notamment et il y avait déjà
une préoccupation de l'impact
environnemental des produits mais la
crise sanitaire de par son origine
l'origine du virus qu'il y ait un
déséquilibre de l'environnement mais ça
pour le coup ça m'a mis un petit peu
plus sa lumière sur les préoccupations
environnementales donc c'est vrai qu'on
verra des consommateurs on a des
consommateurs qui sont très en attente
de comprendre l'impact environnemental
de ce qu'il consomme donc là une qualité
qu'il vit un petit peu plus holistique
un impact sur la santé un pack survient
est le symbole de la gueule de la
qualité c'est le cas le produit local
seuls grands gagnants de la crise ouais
c'est plutôt le grand gagnant de la
crise serait qu on note un essoufflement
de des produits bio qui était pourtant
un vrai moteur de croissance jusqu'à ya
pas si longtemps et aujourd'hui les ce
que nous disent les gens dans les
magasins c'est que le local ça va
davantage signé la qualité que le bio
par exemple parce que le local dans
l'imaginaire des consommateurs c'est
qualitatif et puis en plus il ya un
aspect additionnel qui est c'est bon
pour mon pour l'économie locale
finalement donc ça rajoute finalement un
attribut au choix de ses produits le
coup j'aimerais qu'on parle des
abonnements carrefour monoprix casino de
plus en plus de distributeurs lancent
des abonnements donc moyennant quoi
quelques quelques euros par mois on a
des promotions sur des articles
promotion suis pas de 5 5 ou 10%
pourquoi la grande distribution accélère
ou se lance là dedans
quel est l'objectif c'est de garder en
vie dira un un maximum de clients acquis
pendant la crise sanitaire qu'il faut
garder évidemment assez ça c'est que
quand même voir que la grande
distribution les produits de grande
consommation avant la crise sanitaire on
était péniblement sur une croissance de
1,1 et demie chaque année en pourcentage
hélas la fermeture de la restauration
bâle a engendré un report de
consommation massif y compris sur la
grande distribution et là on a eu des
croissance beaucoup plus forte et du
coup aujourd'hui on revient à une
certaine normalité la restauration est
ouverte donc la consommation depuis
quelques mois lé elle repart en dehors
des grandes surfaces donc dans ce moment
là forcément les acteurs se disent
comment je fais pour minimiser ce reflux
et garder un maximum de ce que j'ai
acquis pendant sept années et demie de
crise sanitaire et l'abonnement c'est
pas la seule façon mais c'est une façon
d'opérer une forme de rétention parce
que finalement l'abonnement on en a tous
dans nos vies pour nos téléphones ou des
plateformes de musique de vidéos c'est
quelque chose qui est assez courant chez
nathan l'alimentaire n'est pas pour
l'alimentaire et l'objectif de sa c2
effectivement moyennant quelques euros
d'offrir aux consommateurs des
réductions de prix à chaque fois qu'il
va passer en caisse et ça c'est une
manière de le fidéliser parce que
forcément quand on prend un abonnement
donne envie de le rentabiliser donc
l'idée c'est que les consommateurs qui
ont souscrit un abonnement dans le
magasin eh bien ils dépensent ils
allouent une part de leurs dépenses plus
importantes dans le magasin pour quelque
part amortir ce coût de l'abonnement un
petit mot d' amazon est ce que c'est ou
pas une menace pour pour la grande
distribution pour les commerces de
proximité
amazon qui n'a pas encore réussi à
percer justement sur les produits
alimentaires ces derniers maillons c'est
le maillon manquant ça c'est vrai que
c'est un peu l'os pour amazon c'est que
les ventes sur les produits grande
consommation chez amazon elles sont très
faibles notamment sur les produits
alimentaires ait cette problématique de
notamment des produits frais qui est pas
qui est pas simple à résoudre un pur
pour le online et c'est vrai qu'en
france en tout cas amazon a pris le
parti de s'appuyer sur le système sur
les experts de la distribution en france
pour livrer des produits donc notamment
avec le groupe monoprix et finalement
revient à son rôle un petit peu
d'origine qui roule deux logisticiens
c'est à dire qu'il va faire le pont
entre le distributeur et le client final
donc assurer la livraison du produit
mais ne pas distribuer en propre des
produits alors aux états unis amazon
ouvre des magasins mais voilà c'est ce
qu'ont ces six dans le carrelage donc la
grande question c'est est-ce qu'ils
veulent appréhender l'alimentation
finalement avec des magasins physiques
ou est ce qu'ils veulent collecter
suffisamment de données sur les
consommateurs sur leurs achats
alimentaires pour demain proposée en
ligne une expérience qu'ils fassent
mouche donc voilà la question est posée
j'ai pas la réponse mais je pense que
les mois à venir lui dire merci beaucoup
et me meyer donc experte à des produits
de grande consommation chez iris c'est
une tendance n'est pendent
[Musique]